you had this branding of being the cute  beetle which i imagine  you didn't like because in a way being  cute means oh i'm not a serious musician  i i hated that i mean that's what  happens just he's the cute one  like oh no no don't call me that i hate  that you know  but once it's said it kind of sticks i  just can't help being cute howard  hey you're  absolutely right come on oh don't ask  her she she really thinks you're cute  i mean like in a big way i mean it's  outrageous  they had to just say he's the cute one  he's the quiet one he's the witty one  and he's the drummer you know the other  day we were discussing on the air who is  the greatest drummer  you know in rock and roll history  someone said neil pert from rush  i said bonzo bonham from like zeppelin  is the greatest  rock drummer to me i'd go ringo top  he's something else second i'd go bonzo  and third keith moon i mean that's mine  i'm going from that generation  right those are pretty good traumas  those boys